[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab rates the life
of her mind an interview series devoted
to learning how women think about their
research their field and their future
let's get started today we are in
conversation with Dr Daphne Joel a
professor of Psychology and Neuroscience
at Tel Aviv University Dr Joel is a
member of the school of psychological
sciences and the Segal School of
Neuroscience
Professor Joel completed her PhD in
psychobiology at Tel Aviv University in
1998 she received the along Fellowship
for young scientists and joined Tel Aviv
University's faculty of Psychology and
Neuroscience
Dr Joel's work focuses on the relations
between sex gender and brain structure
and function she has published over 70
papers and is the author of gender
Mosaic Beyond the Myth of the male and
female brain one of her Central findings
is that while biological sex is not an
illusion our binary conceptualization of
sex is welcome Dr Joel and thank you for
taking time to give us a glimpse into
the life of your mind
thank you for inviting me
so
um maybe we can start with uh what how
you found your way into Psychology and
Neuroscience what brought you what led
you what motivated you
so thinking in retrospect I think most
of the my career was led by a passion I
was going after questions or topics that
I found interesting and look for ways to
all fields in which I could study these
questions so and along the way I started
many things and left many things so I
studied the mathematics physics and
computer science and left after a year
and a half realizing that I don't want
to be any of these and then started
medical school and left after a year
realizing I don't want to be a physician
and I got to study Psychology and
Neuroscience I have a few interests and
really and this is also what left led me
to switch after several years from what
I was studying back in the beginning
um
different disorders related to the Basel
ganglia and their relations with the
frontal cortex to a completely new area
of study which is sex and the Brain
do you is it I don't know if it's fair
to ask as a follow-up do you know in
retrospect or did you know at the time
uh what it was about for example uh
medical school or becoming a physician
that that made you say no this actually
isn't for me and then even within
um studying psychology Neuroscience that
you gravitated to uh studying uh sex and
gender
well regarding medical school I started
learning or started studying and this
the material itself was very very
interesting but I wasn't sure about
being a physician so I went and
volunteered in an emergency room and
quite quickly I discovered that yeah
this is not for me and it's too um
I take it to heart too much the
suffering of others and while we cannot
avoid suffer and suffering of others in
life we don't have to choose this as a
you know a profession and deal with it
every day all day so this is why I
decided not to become a doctor okay and
then so maybe we can um as we talk about
the the work that you've been doing that
ended up being your specialization
um later on uh the connection between
you know being as empathetic as you are
and the what you what you envision in
the in the future for for your field
um so
how did you get to the Neuroscience of
sex and gender as opposed to where you
originally started in in uh Psychology
and Neuroscience more generally so just
really almost by accident so a colleague
of mine and a good friend retired and
she asked me to replace her given a
course of the psychology of gender and
because I I have been a feminist
although I I never studied it officially
in University but from the moment I
remember myself I have been a feminist
so I decided yeah why not I'll teach you
this is an important course to have in
Psychology and so I sat at home almost
for a year reading a lot about gender
and the psychology of gender but as a
neuroscientist I was of course also
interested in sex and the brain and knew
about books like uh you know the female
brain the male brain men for Mars I knew
all of these myths and I wanted to find
out for myself and while reading I read
into a paper again really by by accident
that described sex differences in the in
the rat brain and what they found is
that when the rats were stressed the
differences were reversed now they frame
the the study as sex differences in the
response to stress but what I've noticed
is that this means that there are stress
differences if you want in insect effect
on the brain so how sex affects the
brain can be opposite in different
conditions which was like wow this is
you know not something that I ever
imagined and just because of my surprise
it first led me to understand or realize
my implicit assumptions regarding sex
because you know most of our assumptions
are implicit to us and surprise is a
good opportunity to realize what they
really are so one is that sex effects do
not reverse or change so sexy something
stable and it is always another is a
binary division so and which what I mean
here is that things come in two sets and
well we get these ideas off of course
from sex effects on the reproductive
system or on the genitalia in which this
is quite true so yes in most people the
genitalia come in other one set genital
organs or another set and and they don't
change I mean they develop but they
don't change from the male form to the
female form so
uh this study made me realize that I was
using sex effects on the genitalia or
the binary conceptualization of sex from
the genitalia and reproductive system
while I was thinking about the brain and
this study made me realize that maybe
the genitalia are not a good model to
think or conceptualize sex effects on
the brain so because of this study I you
know I started to look for similar
studies maybe you know this is an
anomaly and I found many so you know
when once you know what you're looking
for and it exists it's a real phenomena
then you can find and and this really
what started my whole journey it started
with a
theoretical theoretical paper in 2011
called male or female brains are
intersex and and only a few years later
I managed to understand how to study the
Mosaic about this probably we'll talk
about it in a while but how to study
this in humans so really I Was preparing
a course on the psychology of gender and
ended up really discovering a new way of
thinking about sex in relation to the
brain and I think now in relation to
many other symptoms symptoms
that are not the reproductive system
okay okay so if so if I if I understand
things correctly
um our traditional assumption is that
the fact of reproductive the stability
if you will of reproductive distinctions
um makes us believe that that that that
stability operates in all parts of us
specifically that it is that it drives
um what the way we think the way we
behave what makes us feminine or
masculine is that is that sort of a a
one way we could think about
the direction of going from reproductive
organs to all sorts of ways we have of
thinking about sex and gender
so I would frame it a little different
and I think the question is how far the
binary division extends beyond the
genitalia okay that's the question it's
not the question of how how far sex
effects extends beyond the genitalia
because we know that sex affects many
systems in the in in our body not just
reproductive system it affects the bones
cardiovascular system fat and muscles
and the brain so sex affects all of
these systems but the question is do
these effects add up consistently to
create two distinct systems as as these
effects do in the genitalia or in the
reproductive system so the question is
not about does sex affect us yes it
affects many aspects but whether the
binary division into female and male
extends beyond the genitalia into other
systems and of course I focus mainly
about the question does it extend into
the brain and mind
what we show is that it doesn't but but
this is an empirical question it's
really important for me to say the
question how far the the division the
binary division extends beyond the
genitalia is an an empirical question
and we developed tools to to answer it
which weren't there and and the point is
that previous Rich research and I'm
talking about hundreds of years because
the quest this question is you know a
scientists have been dealing with this
from the conception of modern science so
we're talking about 17th century many
years but no one ever asked this so the
binary assumption was implicit people
looked for differences and when they
found differences between humans with
male female genitalia They concluded
that this means that there is a male and
a female system a male and a female
brain mind whatever and we actually
tested this and show that this is not
true so it doesn't hold at least not for
the brain
oh that's a lot thank you thank you
thank you
um so
it's what I'm about to ask is maybe
um a bit vague and so I'll ask the sort
of the formal question that I originally
was thinking of and you'll tell me if I
if I'm conflating issues so so my my
question then is okay so
kind of what does it look like I think a
to talk about
um
what is sex what is sex in the brain and
um is it is it fair to then sort of
reformulate that question uh as follows
what is the binary understanding of sex
in the brain is that is that a fair
question yeah we can try okay
okay so let's start with the question of
what is sex which I think is really
important because we use the same word
for many different things
so one we use it for the the binary
division of humans into female and male
which is based on the role in
reproduction and of course lives out
intersex individuals so we can talk
about this later but but
um but for now let's in reproduction we
have two types male and female and even
some intersex people they can sometimes
function as male or female in terms of
reproduction okay
[Music]
um
so this is one meaning of six the binary
division so it's sex category
another is using using the word sex to
describe a system a biological system
which is comprised of genes and hormones
it is very Loosely defined so what
exactly what genes are we included in
this system and what hormones are
included in this system but anyway when
we talk about sex effects on the brain
for example we don't usually mean the
fact that we have male of human
genitalia what we are thinking about is
levels of testosterone estradiol
Etc so this is the sex system not the
binary
categorization into family and male now
the binary framework that comes from the
observation that humans typically belong
to either female or male categories in
terms of reproduction this binary
understanding
effects or biases our perception of any
other thing that is related to sex
including the sex system itself so this
is why people may talk about male and
female hormones
as if humans with male and female
genitalia have distinct sets of hormones
which is of course nonsense so okay so
we all have all hormones all sex related
hormones and most of them in very
similar
levels in males and females
so estradiolin progesterone for example
exist in similar levels in males and
females except pregnant females which
are a class of their own in terms of the
level of these hormones and testosterone
which is in higher levels in males on
average but there is some overlap with
females so this idea of a distinct two
sets of hormones is has no basic basis
in in reality or in biology and of
course in contrast to the biological the
binary division of the genitalia the sex
of the system is always changing now we
are used to think of the changes in in
women in with a cycle the menstrual
cycle but but the levels of these
hormones are changing all the time in
males and females also in response to
environmental stimuli and and conditions
okay so the idea the binary conception
of sex as stable two systems Etc not
relevant when we think of sex as a
system and
um and we really need to get rid of the
binary formulation to actually study sex
what the Sarah Richardson from how what
cause sex itself okay which is the genes
and hormones Etc so this was a maybe
long answer to the first question now
okay no it's lovely thank you it
clarifies uh a lot so because for for
example I was often confused over the
years about why when we talk about for
example sex hormones
there's this distinction when I had a
sort of a vague understanding or a vague
grasp that you know everybody has
all sorts of hormones they're not
distinctly in one uh quote-unquote sex
or the other so what you just meant you
know talked about is is really helpful
so then okay so you had mentioned
um the the uh concept of of intersex
people so people with
um
genitalia that's not distinct can you
talk a bit about so what an intersex
person is and how that person
um helps us understand just what you've
mentioned right about uh uh reproductive
sex versus a sex system but also how how
intersex people
um have been mistreated certainly by the
medical community you know given the
aforementioned assumptions the implicit
assumptions that you talked about
so so we we don't need intersex people
to understand that the sex system is not
binary because it is also not binary
even if you talk about male and females
that are not intersex uh what I think
intersex reveal is that
how uh how the binary conceptualization
or understanding of sex affects biology
affects reality affects people so so the
fact that some you know most human
produce either eggs or sperm which is a
biological definition of male and female
if it didn't have such an important
social meaning
then also the issue of intersex wouldn't
be of importance because the fact that
some people with testicles for example
have a female external genitalia as in
some intercessed condition wouldn't be a
thing because whether you have male or
female genitalia would have no meaning
so we wouldn't be obsessed with who is
female or who is male well intersect
people have a problem because you can
use different definitions uh if if you
didn't have any social meaning
and and it's quite similar for example
when people were obsessed with whether
you are right-handed or left-handed
right yes yeah yeah not very long ago so
there were specific measures to
establish whether you are right-handed
or left-handed and there were also
debates about which is the best method
to Define and you know with The
Disappearance of the importance of
handedness at the social category we are
no longer interested in whether you are
right-handed or left-handed you will not
be hired or not be hired because you are
right-handed of Lieutenant as used to be
the case okay and no one cares whether
you use your left hand and so with The
Disappearance of the importance mean is
of the social meaning of handedness also
disappeared this obsession with whether
you are right-handed or left-handed and
no one would really care whether you are
using your right hand for some tasks and
your left leg for other tests and okay
so the whole I Obsession as a culture
with intersex and also and this is more
problematic they attempt to fit them
into one of the boxes and you know and
carry out their surgeries Etc on very
young babies
so so this is a problem so the social
binary is a problem not sex sex is
biology it's not a problem to be solved
yeah so so
we we so so people over you know
hundreds of years that make observations
they develop uh uh some sort of very you
know obviously informal non-scientific
you know hypothesis and they that
hypothesis becomes a sort of social
framework for thinking about the world
and because we end up with this
um set of structures or categories we
make mistakes
uh about in applying those categories to
to to to people and those mistakes lead
to things like you know mistreating uh
uh People based on their
um
um uh there's a word that I want I can't
think of but based on their uh uh
ill-defined if you will genitalia it'll
defined according to the social right
conception
um and so also you know suffering people
are um kind of forced into ways of being
that simply aren't natural
does that seem like a fair summary of
that yeah
but this is true for all of us okay we
are all forced into two binary
categories just you know for most people
if they are not interested does not
involve surgeries yeah but we are all
false so if you know you're a boy and
someone tells you don't cry don't be a
girl you are forced into a category uh
so in this sense we are all affected and
not in good ways I think by the binary
system and again the problem is the
binary social system
is not whether some people have male
genitalia others have female genitalia
and some have intersects in Italia this
is not a problem
the problem is that we impose on this
reality which is mixed even at the level
of the genitalia we impose the binary
system and when people do not fit the
binary system then we we take very
strong actions against them intersects
people it's it's surgery with other
non-conformed gen and non-conforming
kids adults Etc it's more social
punishing but we are all you know kept
in line at all times
so in
that we can come back to this later but
maybe if you want we can look just to
see um the idea of how how brains are
not male or female because I think you
know at least in this case it's better
to one image was a thousand words yes
lovely thank you okay when you're ready
yeah okay so let me show the this
okay
so as I said
um findings in animals the sex effect on
the brain may be opposite under
different conditions led me to the idea
that brains will not be internally
consistent in having only female typical
or only male typical features as is
almost always true for the genitalia as
we've just discussed but rather Brands
would be comprised each of a unique
Mosaic of male typical and female
typical features and and we analyzed by
now over 20 000 human brains the
structure of over 20 000 human brains to
provide a different types of evidence
and using also sophisticated machine
learning algorithms Etc I'm not going to
go into this I'm just going to show the
basic analysis okay yes so and and only
office you know one subset of brains so
what we did here is we looked at MRI
images of human brains probably you know
most people are familiar with these
images divided each brain into 116
regions
measure the volume of each region in
each brain and wrote it down in a table
like this one and then to appreciate
similarities and differences between the
brains of men and women we use the color
code to paint each cell in the table and
and the idea here is that a cell would
be painted in green
this region in this brain is relatively
large compared to this region in all
other brands men and women combine and a
region will be painted yellow if it is
relatively small compared to the volume
of this region in all other brains okay
so this is how we painted the table and
when we were done this is what we saw
yeah this is why this is the wow that I
wanted so on the left you see brains of
men and on the right brains of women
each line a single brain
and the important part of the part is
you don't need statistics to see that
there are differences between the brains
of men and women
at the group level there's more green at
the women's side and more yellow at the
men's side
but you can also see at the same time
that brains are rarely all green or all
yellow
instead each brain is a unique Mosaic no
two lines are the same of green which is
more common more typical of women and
yellow which is more common in men so I
think these are really important images
because they help create a new
um
a new framework in which it is still
true that there are group level
differences between males and females
but there are no two types and usually
when we hear that there are differences
in the brain between the brains of men
and women we immediately conclude that
this must mean that they're right that
there are male brains and female brains
and here you can see a third option
so the the binary framework in the
binary framework there are only two
options either men and women are the
same or they are different
and what you see here is a third option
we are all different
no two brains are the same so so this is
a I think this is why this is so
powerful for me because it really
provides a new framework of thinking
about sex effects on whatever in this
case the brain I'm getting out of the
binary framework which restricts us to
only two solutions either we are the
same or we belong to two types and here
you see that neither is correct we are
not all the same because everyone is
different but truly we do not belong to
two types okay so this is what I want to
do
to show here
so then so this then is
um I don't know a foundation is the
right word I mean you'll tell us but
this is
um
the Mosaic right so I was going to ask
you so so what is the Mosaic brain you
have obviously your findings but you're
also
um mounting a project uh to to help us
understand uh our own brains as as
Mosaic brains so so what is the Mosaic
brain and what is the project the Mosaic
project
okay so the Mosaic band you just saw so
it's a understanding that brains are
comprised of mosaics each unique Mosaic
I think it was also very clear in the
images that every line is different or
each line is different and so the idea
that each brain is a mosaic of male
typical and female typical features
and also in subsequent studies we showed
that again this is using really
different uh methods of deep learning or
machine learning or whatever you want to
call them
that sex provides no information
the differences and similarities between
two brains so the fact for example that
we both have female genitalia doesn't
mean that our brains are more similar
than the brains of each of us and any
other male which is of course in in
complete opposition or contradiction to
what we know about the genitalia the
fact that you know we are both female so
we share a very similar a reproductive
system which is very different from the
system of any male but in the brains
it's not only not not exactly like this
it's it doesn't exist so sex knowing
someone says sex category provides no
information of how their brain would be
similar or different from yours so this
is regarding the brain what we also also
show that now we are extending this is
that this is also true and I think you
know most people know this this is also
true of gendered characteristics so if
you go to psychology preferences
attitudes behaviors Etc and you look for
features that do show gender differences
for whatever reason and and note that I
do not discuss the question of nature
versus nurture at all okay so there are
differences I don't know why but they
are there but then if you look at the
individual each of us possesses both
feminine and masculine characteristics
okay it's very at least in our studies
it's very well to meet someone that has
only feminine or only masculine
characteristics and and what we are
doing now and let me show you
is is indeed
um we developed it's really only now
started the operating and it's still
quite a better side but uh but we
developed this website and the gender
Mosaic questionnaire in which people can
explore their own gender Mosaic and
learn about gender and and what we do is
first they you know answer a set of
questions about attitudes preferences
and behaviors and just to give an
example for example when choosing a
romantic partner how important is it
that your partner is Rich and and please
you know you and our listeners please
choose a number between zero unimportant
and four indispensable and I'll come
back to this answer in a minute and
after they complete the answering the
question they receive a feedback on each
thread on how feminine or masculine they
are on each trade compared to people
around the world
now obviously what's considered
masculine or feminine differs across
cultures so I can explain how we Define
this and I think we learn about gender
also from from how we Define this so
um we we gathered the data for now
already from over 10 countries on the
same questionnaire okay and we have a
set of 1500 people from each Country and
this is for example the distribution of
the answers for 1500 people from Japan
to the question that we all just
answered and men's answers are in blue
women's answers in red and we can see
that there is a difference okay we can
see the group level difference and
specifically we can see that more women
than men chose answers two three and
four so we would consider these answers
feminine and if this was your answer
then in your Mosaic the corresponding
Square would be red or pink in contrast
Quest I answer zero is more common among
men than women so it would be considered
masculine and marked in blue and finally
answer one it was similarly chosen by by
men and women so it's neither feminine
nor masculine it's gender neutral so it
will be painted in yellow
simple
but what will happen if instead of
comparing your answer or the
participants answered with the Japanese
sample we compared it to the answers of
1500 Americans
okay so this is this the distribution
and we can see that in this sample there
was hardly any difference between the
answers of men and women to this same
question making all answers the neutral
yeah so regardless of how much you you
know how important it is to you that
your romantic partner is Rich now the
corresponding Square in your Mosaic
would be yellow yeah and when
participants finish this is what they
get so this is my Mosaic and when my
answers were compared to the American
sample so you can see in my Mosaic in
some traits I'm feminine or slightly
feminine on others I'm masculine or
slightly masculine and on some gender
neutral okay and this is my Mosaic where
it is compared to the Japanese sample
and to an Israeli sample oh wow okay now
remember that my answers have not
changed yes what is causing the change
from each panel is a definition of each
traitus of my answers of feminine or
masculine in comparison in this specific
culture yes yes so so what you can learn
here is first about your own gender
Mosaic and you can explore and you know
every Square you touch it will open what
exact what feature it is and and why it
is colored this way and some fun facts
about this
um but so you can learn about your
unique Mosaic you can see how you change
in whether you're feminine masculine and
what in comparison to different groups
comparison groups and also you can learn
about gender and and the cultural
dependence of gender okay so on some
rights I I change you know from being
masculine to being feminine right it's
right the same answer but but whether
it's considered masculine feminine has
changed and just a fun fact because we
already have some quite a lot of answers
so this is my Mosaic and of course I'm
not unique and you can see these are the
results of other people so you can see
you know and and again what you can
appreciate here is how everyone is
different so no two mosaics like the
brain no two mosaics are the same and
instead of celebrating this you know
Wonderful variability what our society
is trying to do is take this you know
huge variability and compress it into
two boxes blue and red boys and girls
women and men Etc so
so so this is a the aim of the project
and of course it's uh it's designed both
to provide in very fun way uh the idea
of the Mosaic and more complex
understanding of gender or more critical
understanding of gender especially the
binary
the gender binary and of course we we
will gather information about people's
attitudes behaviors Etc and we can
further explore this uh interesting
topic
oh that I so I did visit the the site
and I filled out the questionnaire what
I if memory serves what I didn't do was
look at the
um cross-cultural comparisons and what I
what I found stunning about your about
just the visual representation of your
brain compared with other brains from
other countries is that like you say
depending on how the culture
um sort of defines uh uh gender
um you get you you change
right so that leads me so so I hope oh
yeah I hope people will will will go to
the uh the gender Mosaic website and
we'll and we'll make sure that we have
the the link up again and I can I can
also say that it's not only in English I
mean the website is only in English but
the questionnaire is available in 10
different language which is so you can
you know so many people around the world
can do it in their own language uh so we
can you know they can be more accurate
and
so so two two questions about the gender
Mosaic project one is
um a question about where kind of what
the the if there is an end point to the
to the project in terms of amassing data
right what is that if there is one what
is it
um and then and then the other question
is uh what do what do you envision
for a a future in which we successfully
break out of binary thinking about
janitor okay so let's start with the
first question so luckily and gladly I
recently received an ERC Advanced Grant
which also supports this project so this
will allow me you know to to keep the
website alive for for longer and this
already allowed me to translate the
questionnaire into more languages Etc so
so I'm really glad really glad and my
vision is that the questionnaire is you
know the website is there and people can
continue to enjoy it for as long as I
have the funds to to keep it active in
terms of the of the research you know
the more the merrier of course and
already the data that we have is very
interesting in terms of cultural
differences in so many aspects just in
the in the things that we measure and
then gender differences in the different
trades Etc so there is plenty of data
there and of course the plan is that it
will be available for researchers
throughout the world not just to us so
it can serve the entire scientific
community
and we of course are focusing mainly on
questions related to the Mosaic and
things like this but but there is so
much data there I mean and we are just
starting that I'm sure others can
benefit and I'm welcoming any type of
collaboration regarding this so this is
a one part the question about a world
without the gender
which is indeed my my vision and I think
if you remember the three uh my three
mosaics different mosaics in different
cultures and you look at it and you
really think you know this is absurd
because I'm the same person with my
unique set of attitudes abilities and
preferences yet whether these are
considered appropriate to people with my
type of genitalia varies across cultures
so and clearly different cultures value
some attitudes and preferences
differently
but the question is why should such
judgments depend on whether we have male
or female genitalia and and this for me
is the most important uh Point
uh and you know when you look at all the
Mosaic that each of our one each as each
of us is and the huge variability uh I
think many people can share my uh
Vision wouldn't it be much better if we
lived in a world in which each of us
could live according to their unique
Mosaic of abilities and preferences
rather than according to the type of
genitalia we have
uh so I I think you know when you look
at this and when you appreciate that not
only you are a mosaic because I think
people know this about themselves
everyone can name a few feminine and a
few masculine characteristics I think
what people do not know and I hope you
know the website will help and our
conversation we have is realizing that
everyone is mosaic
so it's not that something is wrong with
me that I have but the female have some
masculine traits or other male have some
feminine everyone is like this and maybe
we can start celebrating this
variability instead of trying to you
know
deny it uh suppress it in us and in
others
and because I know it's it's difficult
to imagine a world in which sex carries
no social meaning it's just you know one
of our physical attributes like uh you
know eye color or handedness so actually
the example that I give is handedness
because from something so important you
know like 50 years ago if parents or
teachers were noticing that the kid was
using the left hand they used to tie
that hand so the kid had to use the
right hand and also think of the word
the right hand right and wrong right and
left okay so it's so much in our
language and it disappeared
no one cares today you know whether the
U.S president was left-handed this
wasn't a big deal it was a big deal that
he was black not that he was left-handed
Okay so
I wish also you know color the color of
the skin would lose its social meaning
and so I I wish the form of the
genitalia will lose its social meaning
it is important in some situations
whether you have female or male
genitalia mainly situations related to
reproduction so if you want to have a
baby and you want to achieve this by
having sex with someone else then you
need to know what type of genitalia you
have and what types of materials other
person have but but the importance of
sex in our society extends you know far
beyond reproduction and this is what I
want to get rid of
thank you so much for this incredibly
Illuminating uh conversation about uh uh
sex gender and the the reality of our
Mosaic brains thank you so much Dr Joel
we appreciate your time and expertise
before we end is there anything that
you're thinking about that that we
haven't covered that you would like to
to share with our viewers and listeners
yeah maybe one last thing and this is
that you know people in our culture as a
whole are obsessed with the question of
gender differences whether they exist
and where they come from Etc and people
often ask me whether in a world without
gender there would still be group level
differences between humans with male and
female genitalia and and I want to say
something about this because I think
it's important and my answer always been
and always will be that I have no clue I
don't know
whether in a world without gender there
would still be group level differences
between the brain and behavior Etc of
humans with male and female genitalia
but I am certain that in a world without
gender we simply wouldn't care
and that's the important point and and
why should we care if I love I don't
know practicing martial arts which I do
why should I or anyone else care whether
it's more common in humans with male or
female genitalia
we don't care whether it's more common
with human with I don't know blue or
brown eyes
and the important point about this is
that we don't care about this not
because there are many studies showing
that there are no differences between
humans with blue and brown eyes we don't
care because eye color carries no social
meaning
so that's the point A word without
gender is not a world in which everyone
is the same actually it's the opposite
it's a world in which we celebrate
diversity and variability but it's a
world in which we do not care whether
there are group level differences
between humans with this or that type of
genitalia eye color skin color Etc and
and I hope you know people realize why
this is a much better future than the
very restrictive social structure that
we call gender binary in which we all
live now that's a fascinating point that
when we shift our thinking to align with
the the empirical facts
um the sorts of questions that reflect
binary thinking those end up dissolving
mm-hmm
yeah wonderful thank you so very much
for again for your time and expertise
and I hope we'll be able to meet again
and check in on how the gender Mosaic
project is going thank you